Are those cameras in the back? The one
is Al Jazzer, the other is Russia Today
television.
You're banned. Get out.
No, this is the First Amendment lounge,
isn't it?
I'm happy to provide the molt box to
increase your sound quality.
Um, well, ladies and gentlemen,
uh, we're going to continue our program.
We've got uh more great speakers,
including
the finale, Pamela Geller, author of the
book The Post-American Presidency,
who uh is going to sign your copies of
the book.
We're providing those copies for free.
It is an excellent book.
When I started America's Survival
over 11 12 years ago,
there were some who looked at the title,
the name of my group, and said,
"America's survival. This guy is off his
rocker. He's crazy. He's a lunatic
survival.
How is America How is America's survival
threatened?"
Very few people are laughing anymore.
We're in desperate We're in a desperate
situation,
especially when the enemy
can get access to our own
public television stations to the degree
we just documented for you.
But what we're going to talk about now
is an interesting aspect of the crisis.
And I think what you're going to hear
is a very interesting take because
obviously the country survival is
threatened but we're all worried about
our own situations
economically and financially.
And Charles Ortell is somebody who's
able to analyze the economic and
financial situations
visav the political crisis.
And he has developed a reputation
through his many public TV appearances
of being somebody who's been critical of
the Obama administration's quote war on
capitalism.
So these domestic initiatives we see
developing from this administration are
of course being compounded in damage by
the threats we face abroad and we
haven't seen the last of it yet.
Charles serves as managing partner of
Newport Value Partners, established in
2001,
which 2007, I'm sorry, providing value
added research to executives and
investment firms.
In October 2010, he noted that political
conditions inside the United States
seemed unusually polarized and unlikely
to be resolved in a businessfriendly way
for years.
In citing these external threats, some
of which we've been talking about today,
he has developed his own financial
expertise, suggesting that investors
reduce their long-term exposures to
securities and consider increasing
allocations to strategies that trade
volatility and are short-based.
He was raised in Manhattan, graduated
from Harvard Business School with an MBA
in 1980, from Yale with a BA kumlad in
1978, and from Horus man school kumlad
in 1974.
It's my honor to introduce Charles
Ortell.
[Applause]
Well, thank you very much, Cliff, for
that uh kind and generous introduction.
Um I am even though I am a lapsed member
of the silent majority having uh started
to come on television and radio
beginning in September 2008. It was with
great trepidation that I decided to come
down to Washington DC and accept the
invitation to speak here on April Fool's
Day because I'm uh well uh acquainted
with the the famous adage attributed to
Mark Twain. It's better to let people
suspect you're a fool than to open your
mouth and remove all doubt. So, uh, what
I'd like to do here today is actually
talk about three different topics. Um,
I'll give you by way of introduction a
little more color about me and my
background. I want to talk about the
situation in the Middle East, uh, and
why I believe it is among the many
theaters that poses perhaps the clearest
and most significant danger to this
great nation.
Um and then I want to turn our attention
to the structural factors which I
believe uh most major policy makers
around the world don't yet seem to
understand in the west. These structural
factors which are are greatly
complicating our attempts to have a
recovery uh inside the advanced
economies. And then I want to take uh
some time and instead of just being a
critic um I want to uh talk through some
ideas that I think can help get us out
of this mess. So, by way of background,
um it is indeed a great honor to be here
in this room in the First Amendment
Lounge at the National Press Club
because frankly, uh of the 238 nations
that are in the CIA World Factbook, I
know of very few uh that have a similar
organization. And certainly of the 57
members of the Islamic States, I doubt
there's a single one that has anything
close to a First Amendment lounge, let
alone uh a lounge where critics can can
stand up without fear for their personal
safety and express opposing views. So uh
Cliff, thanks again for for letting a
numbers guy uh break into the the
political world here. I really
appreciate this chance. Um you mentioned
some of the schools that I attended and
actually uh I am one of just three
people to have had the privilege to go
to the uh finest school in the world and
that was a school created by my parents.
Uh my mother excuse me has passed away
was a box specialist and got a a
master's uh a bachelor's and a masters
from Yale in 1952 and 1954 which was
highly unusual through the music school.
My father took 19 months off uh to serve
in our with our armed forces, admittedly
from a position of safety inside the
United States during World War II, but
graduated at age 26 with a PhD in
nuclear physics. And they took great
interest in our education, me and my two
brothers. And I think education starts
first and foremost with the parents. You
can't delegate education to the teacher.
You can't delegate uh information,
understanding about the situation in any
country to the press. Ultimately,
understanding your issues, your options
boils down to taking personal
responsibility for reading and getting
into the facts. And as John Adams said
in the famous defense of the British
soldiers that he did not want to take
when the British had killed by accident
Christmas addicts, he said that facts
are stubborn things. And he went on to
say that uh you can't really alter the
state of evidence. Well, that was well
before Al Gore invented the internet
and well before uh Photoshop and well
before the kind of disinformation
campaigns you were talking about with
Alazer and the various people around the
world. And that's why I think it is so
important the work you do and the work
people in this room do who may not be
members of the accredited press but do
the kind of work at home on the internet
digging in and sharing the truth to the
extent we can people around the world.
We live in very very dangerous times. I
I would like to think that this is a
comfortable moment that I could do what
I really would like to do, which is go
back to Oxford or Cambridge and study
medieval history. But unfortunately,
this is not a time to do that. We are in
the midst of what Samuel Huntington
flagged as the clash of civilizations
that's being played out in front of our
eyes. Turning first to the situation in
the Middle East. Um I was one of those
kids raised in Manhattan uh in a family.
I mentioned my father was a scientist.
My mother's father was a Baptist
minister. Both of these people had no
interest in raising us in a religious
fashion. So I don't come at looking at
this conflict as a devout Christian or
Jew or Muslim or Hindu or whatever. I
come at it I think somewhat objectively.
And um I my first experience in the
Middle East was actually being um a
summer intern in Cairo in 1975
in July of 1975. For those of us who
remember history, that was an
interesting time to be in Cairo because
not only were they on the wrong side of
American foreign policy, but it was just
shortly after a a brutal and bitter war.
Um, I had spent a lot of my time up
until getting out there trying to become
a topranked tennis player. So, I had
little interest in all the nicities of
what might be going on in the Middle
East. And I found myself nonetheless
sitting there in Cairo after every
evening, these various insundry exiles
from around the Middle East would would
drag all the Westerners out to the back
and try to get us into all the
complexities of the Middle East. And you
know there are many many points of view
out there um and uh many issues and
there's a long and complex history. The
first question we have to ask ourselves
as Americans is where are our vital
interests in the Middle East? What are
the important things that this small
country we have only 5% of the world's
population 95% of the world's population
is outside our our our borders. Where
should we be spending our energy? I
think we found out in 2001 that one area
has to be understanding who our friends
are and who our enemies are in the
Middle East. and to well I had the
fortune for a number of years actually
uh I retired briefly in 2002 but prior
to 2002 for about eight years I was in
partnership with Nicholas Brady's son
Christopher and through that um I had
access to very high level contacts
around the world very high level
investors around the world we had
investments all over the place and I was
able to look at things both at a high
level and right on the on the ground and
I concluded
uh just coincidentally uh in August of
2001 with all of our contacts around the
world, I felt that something was not
going right. I got very nervous when I
see saw the developments in Iraq uh up
until that moment. I had in the small
world department, I had dinner on
September 10th at San Pedro restaurant
in in uh New York, which is a fantastic
Italian place. I don't own it. Um, and
uh, as I often do in these small
dinners, I was with somebody who had
been president of Jane's Defense Weekly,
and I asked him September 10th, 2001,
what is the chance of a major terrorist
attack in Manhattan? And he said that
night, 100%.
So when I, you know, when it happened
the next morning, um, you know, I really
felt that the business conditions I had
grown to know and felt very comfortable
about, I felt I didn't understand them.
And the more I probed, I felt that
people around the world didn't seem to
understand this conflict. So um, I took
a little bit of time. I laid my
groundwork. I retired in July of 2002. I
also had to deal with a personal issue.
I had to gain custody of my children. I
did that and I had the pleasure of
spending five years out in the
wilderness, not really in Milbrook, New
York. Uh looking after two children and
reading anything I wanted. I had no boss
other than my then 8-year-old daughter.
And uh I could read anything. I could
think about anything. And I I decided,
you know, what are some of the things
that I should read to educate myself?
And the thought occurred to me that for
all the talk about the Quran and the
Middle East, I'd never read the Quran.
And without putting people in the room
on the spot, I would guess that the many
educated people in this room, very few
of you have actually read every page of
the Quran. I went and I I was I had
enough experience to know that a a
standard ruse being used uh to combat
understanding of this is to say that you
haven't read an authentic version of the
Quran. So I picked up the phone and I
figured I had to get to the Council of
American Islamic Relations. And I called
the man up and I said, "I'm thinking of
studying the Quran. Is the Penguin
Classic Edition an authentic version?"
"Oh yes, sir. Authentic version." I
would urge each of you uh to go out and
buy that book. It costs about $14. It is
a chilling document and I think it needs
to be read and people need to
understand, you know, that this religion
is a different sort of religion. Um the
next thing I think we need to understand
is that the situation in the 57 Islamic
states is very different. We're not
talking about Belgium. We're not talking
about Canada. We're talking in the
states, the politically Islamic charged
states throughout the Middle East
region. We're do we have research coming
out, macroeconomic research illustrating
the the the strengths and the
weaknesses, the differences of these
states between states in Europe and
states down uh you know north in in Asia
and and North America. The first problem
you have in in these states is that the
percentage of people who are actually
working as a percent of the people age
14 to 64 is very very low. Okay, this
isn't a case you don't have in these oil
rich states. If you take away petroleum,
you take away natural gas, it's not as
if these people in domain have anything
to do to sell products in the global
market. It's not as if they're literate.
It's not as if they're trained to to
compete in the same way. So to think to
look at the situation in the Middle East
and to see uh what or to think that what
you're seeing in Egypt is Patrick Henry
uh and his wife and Dolly Madison uh
running around Ter Square. That's not
what you're seeing. And uh you need to
understand that as you think about the
challenges that we face out there. Um,
I've been asked to comment uh and I take
the charge up uh with with honor uh
about what I think about America's
foreign policy, what I think about the
president's foreign policy. And a number
of weeks ago, actually, I think it was
more or less the first or second day of
the uh culmination of the Egyptian resol
revolution. I characterized the
president's uh foreign policy as flip
flop photo op. And that's exactly what I
think it is. You may remember that this
president's first act uh upon uh getting
into the Oval Office, among his first
acts was to send the bust of Winston
Churchill back to England. Now I am on
the board of a company in India with a a
close friend of mine. I've known him
since 1978 and he detests Winston
Churchill for what Winston Churchill did
in India which what he tells me if it's
true was truly contemptable and Winston
Churchill has a checkered record in
South Africa but let me tell you in what
he did in World War II contrasting the
famous speech we will never waver we
will never surrender Obama's version of
it in the Middle East appears to be we
will not investigate the facts we will
not make a decision. We will do one
thing, then we'll do the opposite of
that thing. You can count on us to
totally confuse you. And that is what he
has done so far in the Middle East. The
situation in the Middle East is remote
in distance from the United States. But
we still derive too much of our vital
energy resources from that troubled
region in the world. And shame not just
on the Democrats and not just on Obama,
shame on the Republicans because we have
had ample opportunity since 1980 to
reduce our dependence on foreign for
foreign energy sources and that has to
be something we we set our minds to do
yesterday. Uh the situation in Japan
compounds the danger in the Middle East
because I my sources tell me that the
situ excuse me the situation in Japan
with regard to the nuclear reactors is
far more serious than the press
understands today. I've had three years
of experience working in Japan. There is
no Woody Allen in Japan who immediately
opens up all his problems. The idea in
in Japan is those problems are kept well
under the kimono. So we still don't
understand what is going there. We still
are not doing anything anything
meaningful to wean oursel off foreign
oil. And then we get into trying to
dissect what the president says in his
press conferences. Earlier I think it
was this week. Was it 7 7:30 on Monday I
guess that he spoke? Um, I had great
difficulty following his math on the
calculation of the percentage of
imported oil that uh we're getting there
cuz that's not a number I'm familiar
with. I think the percentage is much
higher than he cited. I had great
difficulty understanding how he could
say that we're encouraging the drilling
of of offshore oil and gas. I was
somebody last year who actually I was I
believe the first person to call out the
fact that you need to look at the
timeline on the British petroleum
incident. One of the largest
contributors uh to President Obama's
campaign was British Petroleum. The
decision to invest offshore to allow
British Petroleum to drill that well was
a decision that the president and his
adviserss took after the well was
challenged. And we still don't
understand who got the better of us in
that whole decision to punish BP. My
calculations of that incident are that
BP took the president to the cleaners.
They got to deduct a massive reserve and
take a tax deduction getting cash back
and they haven't yet sent a lot of cash
out to reward our people. So we are
getting in our view in the Middle East
we are being taken to the cleaners as
Americans by the president's foreign
policy in these various countries. Uh
the Egyptian situation I well remember
and I've been back to Egypt a number of
times. I well remember many pleasant
conversations with all sorts of people
in Egypt and it is just a crying shame
to as I did watch the Alazer coverage of
that revolution. Um, I I spent quite a
bit of time actually doing it and I know
a little bit of Arabic. So, I was able
to listen to what the English people
were saying and listen to some of the
words. And I recall at one point um we
were uh the announcer breathlessly said,
"Look at these pro-democracy protesters.
They're so fantastic." And in the
background I could hear what this one
person was saying. He was saying, "One
judge. One judge." Which is an essential
component of Islam. There is only one
judge and that judge is Allah. And that
is not at all consistent with a secular
pro-democracy movement. And I think
we're finding out today that that is so
far away from what we were all were
initially told was the great victory in
Cairo. In Libya, um when I saw that
happening, I'm sure all of us have
connections to to Lockerby. I I lost a
friend um in Lockerby and uh you know to
to hear a member of that government
admit that Gaddafi personally ordered it
then to hear members of our government
say now we're going to compromise. We're
going to engage in a settlement maybe
where this guy's going to get free
reign. He's going to get exile. That is
unacceptable. Completely unacceptable.
And the message that it sends around the
world is ridiculous. I mean, we do have
a mighty military force. What are we
doing? Who are our friends? Who are our
enemies? We don't seem to know. So, this
situation in the Middle East is dire.
And I should pause here and mention I
was born in Los Angeles. I'm an
optimist. So, I I will say that in
advance. I think there's a solution. But
I'm now going to explain what I think
the structural problems are that are
compliment complicating our lives.
all of us, I think, and I first got
exposed to um accuracy in media in the
80s um and I I read Rita Irvine's and
your columns with great interest and I
watched one of my personal heroes,
Ronald Reagan push the country in the
right direction and it seemed like such
a refreshing point in life from 1980 to
1989.
Um everything seemed to be going our
way. If history in this era is written
in English, which I hope it will be, I
think we're going to be looking back at
the period 1989, 1991 to the present as
lost decades.
Think of what we had back in 1991, 1992.
We truly were not only a military
superpower and a global power, we were a
moral power. We had examples of
greatness and goodness. We had brought
liberty and freedom to hundreds of
millions of people around the world.
Now where are we? It is absolutely
disgraceful. What has happened in this
country? Turning first to the economic
side of life. Abruptly around 1999
the demographic problems in this country
began to catch up to us. You won't hear
um respected economic commentators with
the exception of David Walker talk about
and Pete Peterson talk about the the
demographic threats that we have inside
this country. What we have and it's not
just in the United States, it's worse in
Japan, it's worse in Europe. We have the
sad example that as populations get
richer, they have fewer children.
And what that does to the math, the
economic math is it first of all changes
your buying power, your buying pattern
and it changes it lowers the intrinsic
growth rate that's realistic to expect
inside these economies. So where the
wealth is and where the the annual
output is, the picture has gotten
steadily worse, steadily worse since
about 1999. The second thing that's
happened, I remember I'm 55. I remember
in the 60s my parents strategy was to
encourage us to save up for things and
that's what we did that's what we still
do but with a changing
complexion of way the economy has worked
in the United States throughout Europe
and other places the debt levels the the
we've become addicted to debt as a as a
nation in the whole not just at the
household level but in the financial
side of life in companies in
governments. We've just become addicted
to debt. And unfortunately,
we have borrowed all this money at a
moment in time where the bulk of the
world has uh has inaccurately concluded
that we are less risky than elsewhere.
So, we've been able to borrow our money
on low interest rates on lax terms terms
and we become accustomed to doing that.
when this changes, as I have been
warning, the first time I met Cliff
officially was when he interviewed me
after the uh brazenly stupid
announcement of QE2, which I warned back
in early November, will destroy wealth
by at least 20%. I think we're along the
way to doing that, sitting here in on
April April Fool's Day. Um, so we have
too much debt. uh we have an equity
market that is basically you should have
to have in my judgment a license to
invest in the equity market. You should
have to do some basic homework before
you pick stocks. And unfortunately you
can get out there as I mentioned I'm a
tennis player. You can get out there in
the equity markets and have a fun game
of tennis but you're playing against
Roger Federer and you don't know it
until you lose all your money. Right
now, with interest rates as low as they
are, if a if a stock has a very modest
dividend, 2 or 3% yield, it's going to
its value will hold up so long as people
believe that interest rates stay on the
floor. The second interest rates are
driven up, stock prices could crack on
the Dow from wherever it is now down to
6,000 or below in a matter of weeks.
So we are living now at the mercy and
hostage of bond vigilantes. A man who is
hardly one of my my idols save for the
fact that he married uh Mary Maitlin is
u James Carville who who uh I think
correctly pointed out several years ago
that the most powerful people in the
universe are bond vigilantes and bond
vigilantes are beginning to see the
blood in the water that is all over the
water here in the United States and we
next face our next appointment is going
to be with those bond vigilantes who
have been watching
um and I have been watching with a
degree of sadness the poor performance
of our Tea Party elected uh people in
Congress. I've pointed out repeatedly
that the true problem inside this
country, the fiscal problem is not at
the federal level. We have 89,000
government entities in the United States
today, official ones. When you look at
the uh BEA, the Bureau of Economic
Analysis NIPA tables, you'll see that
the total deficit is not as advertised.
It's 1.6 trillion
and it is total spending of 5.6
trillion, total revenues of 4 trillion.
Now, let's put some those numbers in
perspective. The second largest economy
in the world after ours using GDP, which
I don't think is a fair representation
of economic activity. I think it
overstates it. But the second largest is
China at roughly five. Japan, who knows
what it is today, let's call it 4.8.
That there is no other economy as big in
its entirety as $4 trillion. Yet that's
the amount of taxes we collect in this
country. And ask yourselves, and I know
it's dangerous to do this here in in the
the center of government land, but ask
yourself, is $4 trillion enough money to
spend on government? And I certainly
think it is.
I certainly think it is. I think it's
even too much money to spend on
government. We have a situation today 85
or 86 years after Calvin Kulage said uh
as he did and I'm not sure if it was in
Washington but it was to the Society uh
of American newspaper editors on January
17th 1925 Calvin Kulage said the
business of America is business. Today
on April Fool's Day in 2011 in
Washington DC, I'm here to tell you the
business of America has become
government.
And government is ineffective when it
takes in 4 trillion bar and spends 5.6
trillion and gives we our citizens no
real ability to constrain the power of
that spending. The bond vigilantes are
beginning to understand this. They're
looking at the Federal Reserve's
financial statements to the extent you
can actually get through them. And
they're seeing that if you thought um uh
Bernie Maid off had a thing going, if
you thought some of these banks had a
thing going, the Federal Reserve
financial statements, and I urge you to
go on their website and look at them for
yourself, those of you who are trained,
they are not even prepared in accordance
with generally accepted accounting
principles. They use very shaky
assumptions. And the Federal Reserve
Bank itself is woefully underc
capitalapitalized. So it does not have a
lot more latitude to go forward here. So
you look at these big issues that affect
the country and then you get into
accounting for companies.
When I took this time off um I I got
back into life doing a lot of
independent research on a company most
of you would think is a strong company
that's called General Electric. I
concluded to my shock and horror on
Valentine's Day 2007 that General
Electric could be the next Enron and I
began to to ex expound that view around
the world and it is it I recommended
shorting the stock at $39 on August 31st
and it got down as low as six. Then
there was a stealth rescue effort. The
federal government advanced and the
federal FDIC and others advanced a lot
of money in the dead of night and coaxed
investors to put money in October 1st,
2008. That rescue effort temporarily
seems to have worked. But I tell you,
we're about to go into a new crunch when
companies like GE that all of us think
are powerful and strong. Companies like
GE fall and other companies that have
shrunk their balance sheets that have
found too much debt, have taken on too
many contingent liabilities, household
names that we all think as Americans are
strong. When they again crumble
following this extraordinary rescue,
that's going to usher in a new crisis in
confidence. And that is the most
devastating crisis of all. when we lose
confidence in our institutions, in our
banks again,
how dangerous will that be as our
various enemies start pushing harder
around the the globe? I hate to agree
and I I told Cliff recently that I find
myself in a strange sort of hell
standing up here and agreeing or saying
admitting that I agree with Michael
Moore that uh the president should
return his Nobel Peace Prize. Uh but uh
and I also find myself in the very sad
place of agreeing with a not so merry
Senator John Kerry that uh you cannot
have um political or national security
without having economic security.
There's no way to do it. It's very easy
to sit and talk about uh making
everybody equal. I I can I have a
guaranteed and surefire plan to make us
all equally poor. But there is no way
there is no way to keep your liberty and
make us all equally rich. And so the the
policies that this president and
Congress, the Democratic side of
Congress have been following for a long
time to try to hire more and more
expensive government workers to try to
re make us all equal is doomed to
failure. It it it never will work. And
we're unfortunately at that crunch point
when we're about to see us tip over the
edge unless we follow the advice that
Ronald Reagan gave on his farewell
address. Happens to be my birthday uh
January 11th. Um he in 1989 he said all
great change begins around the dinner
table. And so we've gotten together
around the lunch table to uh to begin to
to think more deeply about these issues
in the Middle East, about these
structural issues. And what we think I
think we have to do as groups of
concerned citizens is reach out to our
friends. Understand that 2011 is going
to be a year of disappointment because
we cannot enact change. There is no way.
And frankly, I'm not sure I want to talk
generally about change. I think a good a
good model might be keep the change. I
want my country back. But um we have to
begin now to come up with a credible
plan to engage on the facts, understand
the true pros and cons of our of our
fiscal situation in this country. And we
have to be able as a group to come
together and say, look, if you folks in
Washington, if the best you can do on a
5.6 6 trillion total budget is come up
with 80 billion in cuts,
right? You need to go on a very long
vacation because in businesses I've I've
worked in many tough situations where
you go into a business that is in
trouble and you have to change its
mission. You have to decide you don't
just tink around the edges. You don't
accept the wilds of Washington and all
the insider games. You know, you look at
you say we're spending 5.6 trillion.
Why? You know, what is it that forces us
to do it? And I'll give you a few
things. Uh a as much as I value the
strength of our military. I fail to
understand today why we are still so big
in Japan, Germany, and Italy. I don't
get that. I don't understand why we
spend as much money as we do in those
those places. Yet, we can't control our
own border with Mexico. This to me makes
no sense. And I think we need to go as
as as citizens and say, "Look, you know,
we really do care that our borders are
controlled, not because we're anti-
Hispanic. I have a my my grandmother was
from Brazil and she's obviously not
Hispanic, but I'm I suppose part South
American. And it's not a it's not an
ethnic thing. It's just basically a
security issue. How can you say that you
have a country that's secure if you
can't control your own southern border?"
So we've got to think through through
that carefully. We've got to think
through the big one of the biggest costs
in the budget is education. Why are we
still on an agrarian calendar for
education in a service-based
technologydriven country? Why does it
make sense to stay rooted to 19th
century 18th century tradition and
practice in how we teach our young kids?
Why with all this productivity that's
available to us, why do we need to keep
people in high school for four years,
why couldn't it be three? Or if it's not
going to be in school for for for three,
why couldn't they have an internship for
part of it? Why couldn't we do the same
thing in college and say, "Look, you're
going to to get your degree, you're
going to have to spend four years, but
one of them is going to be in the
service of this country somehow. You'll
be paid, but somehow doing that." Why
does it make sense to have the tenure
system that we have where teachers are
not disciplined? You can't get rid of a
bad teacher. I I I'm a difficult parent
in these schools. I sent my children to
private schools and I had so much fun
fighting with head mistresses and
headmasters. One glorious interchange
occurred when I was told
um before you get started I just want to
let you know that I'm an educator and
you're not an educator. So you don't
know how to teach your children.
That that woman got quite quite a tongue
tongue lashing. But um so in in the
field of education, we need to think
about taking advantage of the many
forward much forward progress that we've
seen so that we can educate our our kids
and give them a chance to to play in the
21st century global economy. I get
people I see a steady stream of resumes
coming into my firm from people out of
some great schools. They're clueless.
They don't know what it means to show up
for an interview on time. You know,
they're coddled. They think they're best
and brightest. Well, they don't know,
you know, that, you know, when you show
up for work, you actually you're the
first one in. You know, you're going to
be working late on Friday and over the
weekend. They don't get that yet. So, we
need some changes there. We need to
think about and this is going to be a
controversial one where I may lose you
but on on the subject of drugs. We are
the largest drug market in the world and
we need to ask ourselves now having
fought a war on drugs for a long period
of time. Is it possible to win a war on
drugs the way we're fighting it? if
we're not prepared to go the Singapore
route where we execute a lot of people,
not just the people who who uh sell the
drugs, but the people who use the drugs,
which I don't think we want to do. Um,
you know, maybe we have to think very
differently about the war on drugs. So,
we're in a desperate moment here. Um, I
applaud Cliff for putting this thing
together. Um I think that uh the
situation in the Middle East is an
extremely dangerous flash point. The
situation with Al Jazzer is I applaud
you for drawing attention uh there and
uh I'd like to just simply close by
saying I'm very happy to answer
questions either now or after the
meeting and uh thank you very much for
putting up with me. Nice
question.
Yes, we got some time for uh questions.
I wanted to make uh one point
uh and that was a phenomenal
presentation
and no I probably didn't agree with all
the points but this is worthwhile
thinking about and I respect the
expertise
that we were just uh given connecting
the domestic problems to the foreign
policy issues.
what Charles said to begin with
about the 57 Islamic states probably not
having a First Amendment lounge
uh brought up a case that we describe in
our report
about bloggers
in particular one blogger in the country
ofQatar now again as if you didn't
already know Cutter is the funer and
sponsor of Al Jazzer
It is based in Doha, Qatar.
And on March 1st, a blogger in that
country
was detained and taken away
uh by the security police
employed by his highness, the Emir.
Amnesty International immediately draw
drew attention to this problem. what had
happened. Quoting the wife of the
blogger who has still at this late date
a month later not been heard from,
raising the possibility that the blogger
who had been critical of the regime's
human rights record
uh is being tortured or worse.
In this case, Al Jazzer, amazingly
enough, uh, did run a brief story about
it, quoting Amnesty International as
saying the blogger had been taken away
in communicado.
And then Al Jazera in its story
said uh something to the effect that uh,
officials ofQatar were asked for comment
and had no comment.
It made me think, here you've got this
multi-million dollar
channel, English and Arabic, based right
there
in a country where this blogger has been
taken away by the regime, possibly being
tortured to death, maybe dead for all we
know at this time. And all this channel
can do is say that they contacted the
regime and couldn't get a comment.
I mean,
where's the investigative reporting?
Where where's the uh ambush interviews
of the Qatari officials about where this
blogger is? Where are the protests
on Al Jazzer itself about what's being
done to a blogger in their home state,
their home country? Just another
indication of how bad it is in the Arab
Muslim world, in a in a country where
they claim that Al Jazzer
demonstrates their commitment to news
and information.
Such a tragedy and such a farce
that this kind of channel can be
presented as a serious independent news
organization
when they can't lift a finger for
somebody in their own country who may be
being tortured as we speak. This is the
kind of hypocrisy that we face with Al
Jazzer. And yet, what did we find the
other night on March 30th at the radio
TV congressional dinner? Al Jazzer paid
for a big table, actually a couple
tables at this dinner, and they invited
officials of the CIA,
the State Department, and the National
Security Council to sit at their table,
giving them respectability
and uh acceptance.
you'll see a a news release we've issued
because
yesterday, the day after this dinner, I
gave a call to another person who was at
the Alazer table by the name of Matthew
Lee of Associated Press, who is the
quote dean of the State Department press
corps, who was listed
as a guest of Al Jazzer at this radio TV
correspondence dinner.
You can see the results of my interview.
He uh he was so flabbergasted because I
was questioning him about his
participation, his attendance at the
dinner and his association with this
terrorist channel that finally he said,
"Wait a minute.
Everything I've told you so far is off
the record." He says, "I've got to talk
to my editors about this." Well, anybody
who knows journalism knows that was a
little too late. If you want something
off the record or not for attribution,
you make that clear before you talk to
the person interviewing you. So, I've
put it on the record. Just such an
absurd position for a quote reporter, an
American reporter to be in to be a guest
of this channel at the radio TV
correspondents association. And then
when I asked him tough some tough
questions about why he went why he took
Al Jazzer's money and got this fancy
dinner, he said, "Wait a minute. This is
all off the record. You know, this is
what we're up against." Uh, and we have
so many in our own media who are willing
to excuse it. Let's go to some questions
for Charles. Anybody?
Let's Sir, let's go.
This gentleman make sure it's
I I want I want to sway a little bit. Is
that on? Yeah. Okay. Speaking to the mic
a little bit, sir. Just so talk about a
little bit about a question about
economical issues that you touched. uh
nowadays we see unprecedented
uh transfer of wealth from west to
Arab countries supplying us with with
oil. Uh
what do you see wrong with creating
similar
concern like OPEC to to create by the
west something like called OPIC
uh organization of petroleum importing
states and somehow connect and match
price of oil with price of goods that go
in opposite direction. I can stand
actually if it's easier. Okay, sure.
Just easier. Um I should have mentioned
um and that's an excellent question. The
problem unfortunately is that there are
now competing systems out there. It's
not the case where the United States can
say you know do it our way or take the
highway. We have you know our view. We
have the Euro Euro European country
view. We have a danger that most of us
had assumed for a while was sort of not
something we didn't have to worry about.
And uh I I don't mean this with respect
with disrespect to anybody but um after
1989 I think many people in this room
myself included probably thought we'd
never have to worry much about Russia
about a resurgent uh Soviet threat. I I
don't think you can safely assume that
anymore. I think you have a different
viewpoint uh of how world should be
organized that's led by communist China
and I don't think we necessarily at all
want to go down that track. I have
mentioned I spent a lot of time in
India. So we have many different parts
of the world that are buying oil and
that have a different way of looking at
dealing with the people who sell oil. So
uh I'm not a huge fan of cartel activity
of any kind. I I think there's no real
need for it. Um in fact, I think one of
the great benefits uh that was created
by our victory in the cold war in 198
and by the ascendancy of the
Anglo-American model was the ability to
create companies uh quickly availing
ourselves of technology that can tap
customers, many more customers around
the world uh than was ever before
possible. So for because I I value our
ability to reach out from our base, I
have a hard time thinking about
countering that approach by uh coming up
with restrictive practices akin to uh
you know the tenure approach or public
sector unions or whatever. It's just
inconsistent with my philosophy. I'd
rather see us um think very sensibly
about our own great energy resources.
Why is it I one of the things we did it
was a crazy project and I haven't told
you about this but I'll admit it at this
meeting we a fellow came into my office
when I was working in a different place
and said I've got a great project I want
to drill for oil and gas in uh Paris and
I said you mean Kentucky right? And he
said, "No, no, no. Think Eiffel Tower,
you know, biggest oil rig on the
planet." And I look at this guy and I
said, "You know, you have a pretty
serious drinking problem, don't you?"
And uh but it turns out that that there
is actually oil and gas in in and around
Paris. And we took over a small business
from the Rothschilds with just 27
barrels a day, which is tiny. And in the
space of uh three years, we had 2,000
barrels a day coming out of shallow
wells outside France. I'd rather see us
do that kind of stuff inside the United
States up in Alaska onshore as opposed
to offshore. We have tremendous
resources. Let's go that way as opposed
to playing an approach that I don't
think really works. Any other questions
in the back? Max, wait a minute. Hold
wait until the microphone comes.
You talked about GE
and I'm going to say thanks to the
internet, especially uh sites like Free
Republic, you get all kinds of
information from all over the world on
all different kinds of topics, all hours
of day and night. And every once I see
something about GE
showing up, the head of GE showing up
the White House all the time. They got a
lot of money and then all of a sudden
they supposedly got almost a uh a
monopoly on the green technology
that's coming up in the future for I
think the solar panels and other types
of machinery a lot of which is not
working.
Do you know of any investigations or
would you suggest a congressional
investigation into
this very interesting relationship
between GE and the White House just as
everybody was blaming the bankers and
the rich people for Wall Street's
problems when many of them showed up at
the White House in the same manner? I
see somebody coming in the back door
walking out with a lot of things in that
bag and I want to know what's in that
bag. Well, I don't know you, sir, but
thank you for that question.
I will try to restrict my answer to an
hour and 25 minutes. Uh gives you just a
few minutes. Um if you are if you were
to Google my name and GE um you would
find quite a bit of public information
uh and analysis uh that our firm has has
put out there. And the GE story when I
first told it to uh to a man uh who
since died, a great man from
last name Mets, he said that the GE
story is likely to to be the biggest
business story of the century. The
reason for that is that it doesn't
uh simply deal only with uh a man who
has to be either the most unlucky or the
most inept man on the planet in
business, Jeff Eml.
It's the GE story. To understand it
properly, you've got to go back into the
tenure under Jack Welch and ask
yourself, is IML just unlucky or was
Welch reputation uh is Welch's rep
reputation for success not fairly given?
And I think we're at that point now. I
think people are beginning you talk
about the intersection of of media and
big business. um
the poor and now you know totally
discredited John Edwards actually he was
twothirds right when he said that there
are two Americas there are actually
three Americas there's the America
people in this room many of whom I would
guess are more the rugged individualist
class um who value property rights who
are out there trying to make the best of
all the greatness that we have in this
land without much government help then
you have the people who are wholly in
the government activity dependent on uh
transfer payments and government jobs
and insulated from the market. And
unfortunately the unholy intersection is
in the middle where GE is between
corporate and government. people who
pride them go masquerade as capitalists
as Jeff IML and and and Jack Welch do
but actually are deep deeply stuck into
and dependent upon the public trough.
Well, we called out we were I was
frankly uh concerned that I might have
lost my mind back in 2007 when I studied
GE for the first time because I'd spent
5 years away from Wall Street and it's a
complicated company and I was working
away and working away and I went into my
my son. I remember the day on on on
Valentine's Day 2007. I said, "Look,
I've reached a point here where I'm
going to go back and get back on the
street and try to get back into
business." And the thing I'm going to
start with is by arguing that GE is the
next Enron. And I need to warn you that
one of two things are going to happen.
Either I will never work again because
it's a pretty powerful company and
they're going to crush me. Or I'll be in
the media and I think you can see what's
happened. Um people most people don't
have the time and energy to go through
G's financial statements the way I've
done it. And I, you know, through Cliff
I I'll happily send research out to you
if you if you're interested. But
basically the financial statements of GE
mask what is truly going on at that
company. Most people think of GE and say
jet engines great company number one
number two. The reality is that G's
activities even today are driven by its
inept financial services business.
If you most research analysts simp you
know the the job of a research analyst
is to maintain good contact with
management otherwise you will not get
the kind of color that you need to get
to put in your in your research and so
the most research analysts tend to be
syphants um I'm independent so I don't
need to do that and um when I started
there wasn't a single research analyst
who had a sell on GE there wasn't a
single financial services research
analyst was credible. Somebody like
Meredith Whitney who had who was
researching GE. So people basically
didn't understand the company. I figured
out a way our firm figured out a way to
show its financial services business
which is deeply wounded. We're in worse
shape today than CIT which is a good
comparable company was back then before
it went bankrupt. Um and then on the
finan on the non-financial services side
when you do look at it the way we do
revenues domestic revenues for the
non-financial services side of GE in
2010 were under what they were in 2008.
Think about that. We've had
extraordinary fiscal support as you talk
about extraordinary government help for
this business. yet they can't get their
revenues in 2010 close to where they
were in troubled 2008.
So, you're absolutely right. And I'll
tell you one person again, the unlikely
alliances that happen in life. I'd never
thought I'd give a shout out to Russ
Fineold, but uh former Senator Fine
Fineold, I guess he's gotten religion
and he's calling for Jeff EML to be
removed from the competitiveness
council. Um I don't I mean I suppose I
do understand why the president would
put Jeffrey EML to lead the
competitiveness
council. He's just trying to prove that
he does not he the president he's
definitely does not understand business
if he thinks that Jeff EML is going to
tell anybody how to create jobs. They
haven't been able to do it at GE. They
when EML took over the company had 200
billion in debt. It now has about 470
billion in debt. It has about the same
hard book value, tangible book value.
Um, there's a great story that the New
York Times had, I guess a week ago, on
on G's uh curious approach to corporate
income taxes. Now, I've called uh on a
TV for uh a 10% corporate income tax
rate because those of us who understand
finance understand that corporations
don't pay taxes. The customers pay the
taxes. So, you know, to call for a
higher corporate income tax is to miss
an essential point. Uh that is that, you
know, you're just punishing yourself.
And we do live in a world with 238
countries. So, somebody else will figure
this out and you're going to bleed jobs
the way we bleed jobs by raising a
corporate income tax rate. But if you're
going to have a corporate income tax,
why not, here's a thought, enforce it.
And the notion that you can have uh let
a company like GE which is I've met with
these people in the past rigorously
controlled from the United States. Don't
think for a second that major decisions
at GE are made anywhere other than in
Stanford and Fairfield, Connecticut. So
to avail yourself of these lower tax
rates, you have to be able to prove that
the decisions were actually made in the
in the countries. I don't think they
could do that. But yet, you know,
they're very powerful. they owned until
recently NBC. Um, and it's a complex
mess. So, it's they're overmatched or
people who might look at it are
overmatched. The the public though is is
beginning to understand this. And there
are two people I like to recognize. Uh,
Tom Burelli and his wife Denine Belli
have been very vocal on this issue and
getting a lot of traction with Glenn
Beck and uh, and Hannity now and also
with with even O'Reilly have been on
this issue. So, I would look for change,
constructive change at GE.
One more question.
Yeah, West
right over here.
Uh, I'm not a lawyer, so I'm not
challenging you here. I'm just asking
because I want to know. Uh Rahm Emanuel,
the Chicago mayor elect and former White
House aid has has suggested has
advocated that every person between
somewhere between the ages of 18 and 24
do some sort of public service. I don't
remember whether he said one year or
two. I'm not certain of that. And uh a
uh a lawyer who practices before the
Supreme Court, Ken Klucowski, who
co-authored a book, recently said that
amounted to involuntary servitude. And
I'm just asking how you other than the
big difference that he wants two years
for everybody just for being alive. and
you want one year after three years of
college that whether or not your
proposal, however well intended, may
violate may run a foul of the 13th
amendment. Well, I I'm certainly not a
lawyer and uh I while I'm happy to give
shout outs to Russ Fineold and Carrie
and Edwards, I have I want no business
being anywhere close to dancing Ray
Emanuel. Uh but what I what I guess what
I'm saying is that as we think about uh
solving our problems, we have to
redefine the mission of government in
this country if we hope to close a $1.6
trillion gap. We have to we have to get
bright people who are grounded in the
facts together to to to in a situation
where you can consider all the pros and
cons of changing things. Um and there
should be no sacred cow. Uh I've got to
believe there's I'm not if you can't do
a requirement
perhaps you can have an incentive uh you
know there must be some way to give
college credit let's say for public
service which I know my own son is
getting at form university. I mean there
must be ways to do it. Uh and I didn't
come here equipped today with a 400
4,000page bill uh to tell you how we're
going to fix the problem.
All right. Thank you very much.
I know I know you're all anxious to get
up and go out and sell your GE stock,
but I uh
I'm going to ask you to stay in your
seat. Lee, would you come up?
Exactly.